Antoine Allen, Filmmaker: He says
I wouldn’t know him for years,
we don't understand this that's fine. Why I
didn't understand he became a billionaire.
Film Courage: Have you ever met Tyler Perry?
Antoine: No, but he's one of my biggest
influences from the business side because
when I started in the music business
I had people like a Jay-Z or the
Cash Money or Master P or 50 Cent that
had structure but when I came in the
film business I was like Ya’ll don't own
nothing Ya’ll don't own none of your films
but Tyler Perry showed me the industry
way to do it so he's my biggest blueprint
of how to truck your business and own your
catalog and so he's yeah he's a great guy.
Film Courage: When you
first saw a Tyler Perry film
how did you start researching him to
really dissect how he does things?
Antoine: I didn't have to research him. There was
bootleg videos everywhere. Before we had all this,
a lot of his plays and movies were bootlegged so
it was everywhere. He had plays in New York so
he was just everywhere. So he was like Oh this
is how you do it, this is how you do it because
he's really the only filmmaker African-American
filmmaker where I know that have a large catalog,
like his kids are fine. There’s people that
own their films but his catalog of ownership is
just like…the Medea catalog alone is just
ridiculous. I’ve never seen this
done before. So it was amazing.
Film Courage: Did you say I want to do the same
types of films or you had your own spin on it?
Antoine: I had my own vision. I didn't want
to be one of filmmakers that does all those
100 studio films but I own nothing so I'm big on
ownership only so you got to own something like it
don't make no sense that auto directors those auto
films you know no IP [Intellectual Property] like
it don't make no sense like I don't I don't
even fan them how how you could work and do a
whole bunch of films and on anything like I read
the article with Sylvester Stallone and he was
talking about how he don't own nut in the Rocky
franchise he had no ownership I was like how did
this happen but back then you know he didn't have
the right people around him but he did a article
recently he complained about it that he doesn't I
mean he get paid but he does the own no IP of it
I forgot who owns it but he doesn't own so in
my film when I heard that Lola is a franchise
I own the whole franchise but you gotta you know
I'm big on ownership don't make no sense to me
like when you watch Jason [Voorhees] Jason in
space, Jason goes to Manhattan like they don't
the person that really did Jason do not own
this IP that does the movies like that so I'm
big on ownership you have to own something
what if someone says I'm going to give you
this amount of money to sell this Lola franchise
this little idea this this character and
you won't own it you're going to sign over your
rights but you're going to get x amount of dollars
whatever that makes sense so like Lola one little
two have ownership in it but I just have to make
sense I just have to make it have to make some
type of sense but right now no nobody so if it
doesn't make dollars it doesn't make sense yeah
you gotta make sure that makes sense even if even
if I say hey here's some ownership I'd do another
franchise but it gets it don't make sense to do
like I'd be seeing filmmakers make like a hundred
films you know on one movie like one so I'm big on
IP because but most somebody's only thinking about
IP like all those big studios got ninja turtles IP
star wars marvel like that's heavy IP catalog but
most filmmakers don't understand that but you got
to look at legacy you know when I'm not here I
want to give my kids something I don't want to
give them hey your dad was a great filmmaker
but I'm broke so I want to give passing down
do you have kids not yet my wife is
working on kids now oh okay all right
okay if if your son or daughter wanted to be a
filmmaker would you say great okay how much do
you know about Tyler Perry and how he got his
start I know everything when I look at somebody
that I relate to I really studied him like he his
story is when they make his movie it's it's it's
going to be amazing but your history he's just
he's one of one he's like a one percenter you
know if you go research someone did it before
him was years ago I always mess up his name
Oscar Michaeux I probably mess up the name
but yeah I can research it Oscar Michaeux he's
one of the black filmmaker and back in the day his
films didn't want to take it so he started his own
studio stopped using his own films and yeah so
todd perry is like my mirror to go to when it
comes to ownership and building your own empire
like I said it's okay to give some films away but
own something and Tyler Perry was homeless at one
time he was homeless I was homeless so how much
does does that factor in because you know how in
the film industry it seems like a lot of people
come from you know more of a a middle-class helped
background and I know I get some flashbacks and
and so and and people can be mad if they want but
but that does set a foundation that does help you
you know whether it's just parents know
somebody and they can get you a job somewhere
how much does that help you relate to that
person when you see that they they came
from humble beginnings or I don't even know
what his family situation was like I don't
know why he ended up homeless but well
he has seen family I had broken family
he got molested when I was younger I went
through some of that but yeah you come from
some people when you come from that trauma it's
two things gonna happen you're gonna die in trauma
or gonna turn your pain into purpose he turns pain
into purpose he helped a lot of people so he's one
of the people that I look up to and influence in
my life and so he initially started doing plays he
was on plays about the church or the church
and what he taught me is know your audience
he had a huge onus like a rev Hughes and he just
knew his market and when I'm looking at certain
things he's like one of him 50 cent a few other
people but him and 50s the two people that we look
up to in terms of what Tyler Perry's been able to
build what's the top inspiration for you he did it
he did it with no help I mean he had help but
he he didn't come from the beginnings of family
hey I know this person in that studio I can
give you a job he literally got it out the mud
he started with nothing and he built this amazing
empire to help a lot of people so that's why I
look at it because at the end of the day it's easy
to be oh I did all this stuff who'll help you like
I have a friend that he brags about but his father
works for a big studio so you take his dad away
his story when her story gonna end
because he don't have that drive
so that's why there's tala people like Tyler
Perry the 50 cents in the world and everybody
they come from beginnings I can relate to well I
mean and in fairness to people who do come from
you know more of a a money background it's not
their fault it's not their fault and they can't
help it but it's also what they do with the
opportunities that they're given because i've
seen both you know some people take it and they
run with it and that's great and then others
it seems like they don't and I think that's the
frustrating part yeah for people that don't come
from that because they're like you're wasting
this you know and it makes you angry not just
jealous but it's just like that's that's wasted
yeah when I look at it I tell people at times you
come for nothing you come from a lot of money
at the end of the day it's all about execution
I know people that would have a lot of
money they ain't doing anything so it really
comes down to you so don't let your beginning
don't let your family and friends that have
money you if you really want it you're gonna
do it no matter where you come from so I know
friends that i've been looking after like how
what what like you have all of this like what
but I realized at the end of the day that's in
your DNA the hustle like the house is so separate
you have everything you want the house is so
separate and that house is going to get you to
the next level like look at 50 cent for example
50 cent they don't know if Curtis 50 Jackson his
beginnings everybody nobody got shot blackboard
that stuff what he was able to do at stars network
no one could never do this he took a network that
no one cared about like I had stars I didn't know
what stars was I was like why am I paying for this
no one knew about this thing he took this network
and turned into his own marvel I never seen a
drama series break off in different series like
like it's marvel like what he did was just
incredible so once again it's producers have
been in the industry for years they can't do what
he do it's in his dna the house is so separate
what is the hustle passion anything
necessary execution do what you have
to do to get where you want to go and get out
your comfort zone and don't settle for less
but then going back to that party where people
were enjoying themselves and in ways that
sometimes people think it's just one weekend
and they'll be fine they can walk away from
it and then if you've ever been on the other side
of that you see that that one weekend is going to
turn into months and years like me I don't smoke
I don't drink I barely go to parties because
I'm at point my life right now that I don't
have time to have a whole weekend partying
I could be doing something else it's okay to do
and dab but don't have to party but your whole
life so any means necessary does not mean enjoying
and joining for one weekend when it could it could
catch you yeah it means necessary is if you have
a film project like for me for example right
it means necessary lola when I could get
investments I did always talk about my job
I don't like my job but I did what I had to do
I worked at my regular job I did what I had to
do I didn't wait I just did what I need to do and
I saved up my money one of my 401k and invested
in my movie oh wow okay so anyway necessary
you it's it's we have too many options now
it's no more gatekeepers you don't order people on
tick tock and youtube and instagram that's making
their way and making money and paying for their
family no more gatekeepers no one can tell you no
the only gatekeeper is a person remember and that
was for lola one yeah okay one of my projects
majority of my projects those two my new movies
the first film that I had a producer really paid
for everything but but yeah most of my films I
funded what are the things that you've learned
from reading and watching Tyler Perry as an artist
and a business person that anything is possible
but that you that you have taken on like like
specific things not just anything is possible
only your content trust in your
vision loving yourself first
don't listen to the industry because
Tyler Perry he's just not getting flowers
they the Hollywood he says
hallelujah knowing him for years
we don't understand this that's fine why didn't
he understand he became a billionaire so it's
noise you look at you know Hollywood was it
made for African-Americans it just wasn't
so a lot of times like the image just passed
abroad complaining oh the enemies it wasn't
made for you it's like being in a relationship
if you're a person keep cheating on you and
disrespecting you don't go home leave so we have
to realize that though auto industries all those
structures wasn't made for us so if they're not
made for you make your own go somewhere else
it's no one gate you could go to there's so
many other options that's nothing you taught me
options when the big networks that you're trying
to go you're trying to pitch your film or picture
project they say no it's okay but when they
say no it's not really no it's no right now
because they can't see the vision so when when
we know that something is not right for us like
an industry and there's hashtags that say whatever
Oscar's so white or whatever and so we know that
but then at some point though they go oh yeah
I like that and you see like okay now they need
us or now they need our picture what do you say
to that okay I’ll play this time this is up to
you it's the individual we play this time write a
bigger check it's all up to you but at the end of
the day eventually they come around you can't
like top her make so much noise now they're
coming around so this is this is part of it so
though what's that one saying oh be so whatever
that they can't ignore you yeah okay that's what
he did he like now they can't you know now he's
working with Netflix so eventually they even gonna
come now they come later but they're gonna come
if you build it they come okay but then don't
don't expect do do it your way and then when
they're ready then they'll show up whether it's
music yeah it doesn't matter don't wait like don't
don't be there knocking on the door and wasting
100 years knocking on the door and say please
I wanted to see at the table when you
build your own table the food tastes better
so build your own table like back in the day
I get it back in the day was hard now you make
phones you make moves on your iPhones you can just
do so many options now that you don't need it.
What did you like about this video?